for the first time in years amd is
punching toe-to-toe with nvidia's
high-end
gpus the recent rx 6800 and 6800 xt
demonstrated just how powerful the rdna
2 architecture is
and just how competitive it is those
gpus are definitely worth considering
that is
once they finally reach some reasonable
capacity on store shelves
but this i cannot say the same for this
is amd's new 1 000
rx 6900 xt which claims to offer the
fastest pc gaming experience that you
can possibly buy
its main objective is taking down
nvidia's 1500
rtx 3090 and that's going to be the main
point of discussion
in this review but i think the main
question that we need to ask ourselves
is
who would buy this over an rtx 3080 or
even a 6800 xt
gpus that are hundreds of dollars
cheaper and may not be that far off in
terms of performance
so let's dive right in compared to the
6800 xt the 6900 xt
has eight more compute units and ray
accelerators 512 more stream processors
but the same memory configuration board
power and clock speeds
so roughly 11 more compute silicon under
the hood
but for a 54 price jump the 6800 xt has
an msrp of 650
whereas the 6900 xt starts at a grand us
keyword there being starts at because as
we've seen
the actual pricing of these cards is a
bit more in reality
that's also the case for most of
nvidia's 30 series gpus excluding the
founders edition models
which do seem to be selling at the
listed msrp but
only in selected regions and outlets so
seeing as we've had so many gpu releases
quite recently
instead of dragging you guys through a
ton of graphs like i usually do
let's get to the bottom line on this one
quickly at 1440p resolution i found the
6900xt to put up a pretty solid fight
against nvidia's rtx 3090
and for 500 less it's a bit faster in
some
virtually tied in others and loses
marginally in a couple here and there
this graph shows the percentage of
performance gained over the 6900 xt
over the rtx 3090 and especially when
you consider the price to performance
the 6900 xt is of course the better
pick but that lead fades away when we
look at 4k resolution
now the results are in strong favor of
the rtx gpu
the 3090 has a much faster memory
configuration and bandwidth than the
6900xt
and that's likely why it's doing a bit
better here at this higher resolution
of course though that price difference
one thousand dollars
versus one thousand five hundred dollars
considering that the 6900 xt
looks pretty damn good except when you
compare it to an
rtx 3080 or even one of amd's own gpus
the 6800
xt remember there's just an 11 increase
in compute units here for the 6900 xt
over the 6800
xt and funnily enough that's the
performance increase that we see here in
red dead redemption 2 at 1440p
that lead increases to around 16 percent
when we look at 4k
and that might be due to the slightly
higher texture unit count and texture
fill rate on the 6900xt
but as we saw in those initial graphs
the 6900xt
isn't faster than the 3090 in everything
and i want to make it clear that i never
recommended the 3090 as a gaming gpu in
the first place
actually i can't remember a single
reviewer that did
you'd be totally mad to spend more than
double the cost of an rtx 3080 for
around 10 to 15 percent more gaming
performance
in fact the 3090 is the worst price to
performance new gpu that you can buy
right now
so the fact that the 6900xt can beat it
in that arena
while also beating it marginally
outright in some titles
i just don't find that impressive and
just to be totally clear this isn't even
about team green versus team red or
picking aside even against the 650
6800 xt the 6900 xt just looks
unjustifiable in death stranding at 4k i
found just
a seven and a half percent performance
difference between them so i guess what
amd wants to see
and market are graphs like this graphs
where the 6900 xt is at the top of the
stack
offering slightly more than the 3090 for
a whole lot less money but it's just not
that impressive considering other high
performance gpus like the 6800 xt and
the rtx
3080. it's even less impressive when we
consider the ray tracing performance
that feels a whole generation behind
what nvidia's ampere gpus can currently
do
here we're looking at the new watchdogs
legion at 1440p with the ray tracing
preset set to high
now the 6900 xt actually beats the 3090
in this game
without ray tracing enabled but turning
it on creates a clear cut in the gaming
experience between them
then factor in dlss which a good deal of
ray tracing enabled games in the future
will likely include
and the gap grows even wider you might
have also noticed the periodic frame
time spikes on the amd gpu here
that occurred both with and without ray
tracing enabled so hopefully we can see
a driver update to correct that but even
in a title where
that doesn't occur ray tracing
performance is really lagging behind
nvidia even without factoring in
dlss now at this point most of you get
it so we'll end this part of the
discussion here amd just isn't
competitive when it comes to these
graphics features
amd also said in a recent media briefing
that the 6900xt is primarily a
high-end gaming gpu and not focused on
performance
when it comes to creative applications
and here you can see
why they said that in blender the 1000
6900 xt
loses to the 400 3060 ti
and that's without factoring in the
faster optics render engine for rtx gpus
and i've mentioned in this review that
the rtx 3090 is
also a hard gpu to recommend based on
gaming performance alone
but i can still recommend it when it
comes to creative applications or render
engines based around
cuda in my opinion that's really the
only thing that the 3090 has
going forward otherwise it'd easily be
in the same bucket as the 6900
xt a really expensive gpu that is
unjustifiable for gaming
although some creative users can benefit
from the 3090s
gigabytes of gddr6 x memory and
excellent
application support and i'm aware that
the 3090
lacks the proper workstation drivers to
make it competitive in
engineering simulation and research
applications which is a real shame for
those users
but that's not actually relevant to the
majority of creative apps and
render engines so for 3d artists
professional video editors and users of
that kind the 3090 can still make sense
if you find yourself running into a
video memory limit the 6900xt on the
other hand i find
impossible to justify for any user if
this
is truly a gaming focus gpu as amd have
claimed
it should be substantially faster than
an rtx 3080 or 6800 xt
then when simple functions such as
recording my own desktop
don't even work i find the price tag of
one thousand dollars us just
straight up offensive that's not even
factoring in what the real price of this
gpu is actually going to be when it hits
store shelves and whether there will be
any reasonable stock in the first place
the 6900 xt uses the best
silicon among the entire radeon 6000
lineup
and naturally that means much lower
yields than the 6800
and 6800 xt even those gpus are an
extremely
rare site for now so in closing among
all of the
recent gpus that have launched in the
last few months i feel like you could
justify
any single one of them based off price
performance
in your region or the features that may
or may not matter to you
the 6900 xt on the other hand i just
can't find any reason to justify
at all in some games it is the fastest
gpu that you can buy but
when that is just you know five to ten
percent sometimes over a 6800 xt or a
it is just not worth it in any sense so
i think we'll end the review there if
you're interested
in buying some other gpus i will have
them linked down below
as always a huge thanks for watching and
i will see you all
in the next one